bonjour nous allons tous vieillir nos
proches nos hainaut et man dont vieillir
aussi ça fait peur
vous la savez pas à distribuer des
médicaments là moi je disais moi moi
c'était mon métier savait le faire moi
dans mon temps ça se passait pas comme
ça on regardait pas les jours de congé 1
on nous rappelait au travail mais
maintenant c'est plus pareil
maintenant les jeunes ça pense qu'à
dormir qu'à s'amuser pendant ce temps là
ils font des erreurs sur les médicaments
je veux retourner voir mes enfants ils
sont là bas ils sont à l'école je
retourner les voir y matin mes enfants
pour que j'aille le chercher à l'école
mais avec moi faut que j'aille chercher
les enfants à l'école
ça vous donne le frisson moi aussi j'ai
eu le frisson ça a commencé en 76 mes
études à paris la belle vie je croyais
que j'allais être une bonne affirme hier
que tout se passerait bien
premier stage salpêtrière les grandes
salles demoiselle vous irez distribués
mais les les thermomètres
dépêchez vous car en termes nets 40
chambres
j'en ai fait tomber le plateau en 80
premiers postes
c'est une infirmière fier de l'être se
retrouve dans un service de salle de
réveil
les chirurgiens les anesthésistes
vraiment un beau métier
j'ai pu ainsi arrêté de savoir qu' il
fallait être présent une salle de réveil
ou d'or prenez la tension prendre la
température
j'ai pu aussi quand même réaliser des
soins techniques je suis devenu une
technicienne du soin en 1981 j'arrive à
un dangereux premier poste d'infirmière
libérale à là j'ai pu rencontrer les
personnes âgées à domicile
il m'offrait le café on s'asseyait on
discutait raconté un petit peu leur vie
leur histoire j'ai pu vraiment côtoyé
leur générosité leur savoir-être leur
sagesse c'est même que soignerait
quelques années plus tard fragile 82
j'ai 25 ans
première création des postes de cure
médicale
je suis jetée dans la gériatrie sans en
avoir eu aucune formation
on me présente les résidents aligner le
regard vide sans paroles 1991 des amis
se passe et là je rencontre quelqu'un
qui va bouleverser ma vie mon chef de
service momen voir une conférence ici
même à dijon une psychologue américaine
qui parlait d'une méthode empathique la
validation
enfin je retrouve ce que je cherchais
quelle est cette méthode même méthode
est basée sur le fait tout simplement
que vous soyez vieux ou jeunes en bonne
santé ou en errance vous êtes un être
humain unique avec une histoire de vie
et que que vous soyez valide ou pas
valide
il faut vous écouter vous avez des
émotions ses émotions il faut les
percevoir
mais en 76 on m'avait dit tu laisses tes
émotions aux vestiaires donc il a fallu
apprendre
l'empathie c'est ckoi l'empathie
observer écouter et être à la hauteur de
ces personnes ces personnes elles ont
une histoire comme je voulais 10 qui a
été semé d'embûches de bons moments
comme vous et moi
et puis elles ont mis un couvercle sur
leur histoire
elle n'avait pas le choix à cette époque
là on racontait pas concrètement par une
parlant comment ça se passe je veux que
vous vous occupiez mais moi je veux
maintenant que je veux ma soupe vous
êtes en colère
vous avez fait la soupe dans le temps
c'était bien la soupe
racontez moi comment vous faisait la
soupe mes enfants mes enfants mes
enfants où ils sont mes enfants plutôt
que dire
et là je vous avais madame 90 ans mais
vos enfants ils sont grands vous avez
été une bonne maman
parlez-moi de vos enfants comment ça se
passait quand il était petit qui s'en
occupait
et cette personne ce proche prostré
donnez moi votre main on va chanter une
chanson voulaient confiantes ensemble
donc voilà la méthode est à la fois
simple mais pas accessibles dans les
mentalités scientifique actuel préfère
mener des médicaments 1
c'est quand même plus facile les
contentions ça existe aussi une fois
j'ai pu accéder à cette méthode
j'ai eu le bonheur de pouvoir la
partager dans une équipe
nous nous avons donc une maison de
retraite
je vais vous la faire visiter dans le
hall un grand arbre est derrière des
tables en peinture la place du village
parfois les personnages et s'installe en
effet la guinguette
on chante on danse on reçoit les
familles vous passer après dans la pièce
de réception et là j'ai anime des
groupes de validation une groupe de
validation
c'est un moment de partage d'expression
des émotions de ces personnes prostrés
frustré silencieuse qui se mettent à
philosopher sur la vie la mort parle de
la mort c'est tabou la mort j'aime bien
qu'on en parle
plus personne n'en parle de la mort on
parle de la vieillesse on parle de la
jeunesse est ici veille
ils deviennent vivants ils ont de
l'humour
un d'eux m'a dit ici on n'a qu'une chose
à faire à être choyés
voilà
la méthode est telle qu'elle est
c'est-à-dire donner de la tolérance à
ces poules du comportement accepter
cette désorientation les accompagner sur
un bout de chemin sans vouloir les
ramener vers la réalité c'est apaisant
pour tout le monde
apaisant pour les familles qui ont enfin
une nouvelle relation un nouveau contact
apaisant pour les soignants qui eux on
leur donne du sens à leur travail et
apaisant pour la personne âgée qui est
là pour finir sa vie et partager les
derniers moments de son existence
pouvoir exprimer ses émotions
j'espère que vous aurez plus peur de
vieillir
j'espère que vous saurez communiquer
avec vos anciens quand il sera le moment
je vous assure que c'est un moment de
partage et de bonheur et d'amour